Speaker 1: I need 11,000 votes. Give me a
break. That's a quote that many of us remember
that relates to Georgia. That was during a
phone call that the failed twice indicted,
twice impeached former president had on the
phone with Georgia officials saying, I only need
11,000 votes to defeat Joe Biden. Give me a break.
Let's find those votes. Trump claims he was saying
just I think I won. Let's just find the legal
votes. Every other sane person in the world who
heard the audiotape says no, Trump's trying
to coerce and say, find a way for me to win,
even if Joe Biden actually won. It turns out
that it was not only in Georgia that Trump was
doing this. And this once again fits this theme.
We get one report, and many of his defenders say
so out of character. He would never do this.
We now have two independent, unrelated reports,
Washington Post exclusive report from our friend
LeAnn Caldwell from the Community Radio Days,
Josh Dawsey and Yvonne Wingert. SANCHEZ
Trump pressured Arizona Governor Doug Ducey
to overturn the 2020 election. It reads just like
the Georgia story, but it's a different story. In
a phone call in late 2020, Trump tried to pressure
Republican Arizona Governor Doug Ducey to overturn
the state's presidential election results, saying
that if enough fraudulent votes could be found,
it would overcome Trump's narrow loss in Arizona,
according to three people familiar with the call.
Trump also repeatedly asked Vice President Mike
Pence to call Ducey and prod him to find the
evidence to substantiate Trump's claims of fraud.
Pence called Ducey several times to discuss the
election. They said, though he did not follow
Trump's directions to pressure the governor,
the extent of Trump's efforts to cajole Ducey
into helping him stay in power has not before
been reported. Even as Trump's other efforts
have been made public. Ducey told reporters
in December 2020 that he and Trump had spoken,
but declined to disclose the contents of the
call. Although he disagreed with Trump about
the outcome of the election, Ducey has sought
to avoid a public battle from Trump, and notably,
Doocy did not record the call, according to people
familiar with the matter. So we now have. Yet
another story we have now heard. If you look
nationally from county election officials,
state election officials, state legislators,
we have heard from all of these different
levels about a very specific sort of plan.
We know that there were elements to this attempted
coup that went all the way to the White House.
It included the January six rioters, the halls
of Congress, fake electors and various states,
pressure phone calls, attempts to
commandeer voting machines. Remember,
every one of these little details would have been
a crisis if Obama had done it, that's for sure.
Speaker 4: Obama now.
Speaker 1: But they are
just yet another instance when it comes to Trump.
There was that period right after the elections
where Trump said sequester the voting machines get
voting machines. Officials went to Trump and said,
What are you talking about? We can't really
do that. What do you mean? Just bring them
here to the White House? It doesn't make any
sense. We at this point can make a couple of
conclusions. Number one, these people were not
randomly acting alone. You didn't randomly have
fake electors in Arizona and fake electors in
Wisconsin all trying to do the same thing. Just
by mere coincidence, it is obvious that this was
a concerted and coordinated effort. Number two,
some of the same tactics and techniques were
attempted in multiple states. The pressure phone
calls were attempted in Georgia and the pressure
phone calls were attempted in Arizona. Now,
the questions that remain and I don't pretend to
have the answers at this time, we just don't know,
is special prosecutor Jack Smith looking into what
we just learned about from Arizona? Is it possible
that this will become part of his investigation
or is this being independently investigated at
the state level in Arizona? Much like Fani
Willis is investigating the same in Georgia,
from which we will soon know the outcome
sometime between next week and early September.
We don't know the answer to that, but what is
abundantly clear is that this was a concerted
effort. Loony Lindsey Graham seemed to have
been involved in multiple places. By the way,
Lindsey brutally booed at a Trump rally
over the weekend. We'll talk about that
in a moment. That's the latest. And
it is crimes, crimes and more crimes.